I'm Laura Ingram this is the Ingram
angle with a very big show tonight so
let's get right to it the day the Happy
Talk died that's the focus of tonight's
angle
now for all these months the Biden team
they basically waved off concerns about
the economy claiming that things would
kind of even out that this was kind of a
transition to more sustainable growth
we have a very strong economy I know
people are very upset and rightly so
about inflation but there's nothing to
suggest in inflation and that if it are
recessions in the works I believe there
is a path through this that entails a
soft Landing with the economy
essentially stabilizing
well how's that soft Landing feeling to
you guys out there tonight
how does that woman still have a job
when so many Americans are now at a risk
of losing their jobs well we know why
she became the first woman in the 232
year history of the U.S Department of
Treasury to hold that position
oh come on being a first was always more
important to Biden than someone actually
being the best and now we're all
suffering for all the incompetence
now the Dow is 746 points lower than it
was on inauguration day for Biden that's
that means all the gains that we made
under Trump were totally wiped out and
that's before you account for inflation
and by the way things are about to get
uglier Walmart announced that it would
only hire 40 000 retail staff for the
holiday shopping period well forty
thousand sounds a lot but until you
realize that last year Walmart hired a
hundred and fifty thousand holiday
workers
well Biden with his team of incompetence
you know starring in the what grinches
who stole Christmas it looks like it but
in the updated take on the old classic
instead of a growing heart Biden just
has a shrinking brain
rosh hashan
the non-proliferation of proliferation
proliferation ideals embraced by Every
Other Nation
the fact is there is no Biden Brain
Trust it's only brain rust
they somehow convinced themselves I
guess that they could trust the FED to
fix everything that was going on in the
economy no matter how much they spent
that no matter how much money they
borrowed printed and wasted there would
just never be any consequences for
Americans
but Larry Summers of course the old uh
Obama treasury secretary he saw this
train wreck coming back in the spring of
2021.
now let's be clear the former treasury
secretary wasn't trying to undercut the
Biden team he was trying to save them
he's a loyal Democrat
but the laugh the regime media the
adults and the Biden Administration they
didn't care they just waved him off
they truly thought that they knew better
so they pursued Reckless spending and
grandiose plans to remake American
capitalism
and now they're facing a November
Wipeout
and the American people are facing a
long period of Decline and despair
tonight
meanwhile reality is coming for Biden's
foreign policy as well
now here again we've been fed months of
Happy Talk remember when we were told
that sanctions on Russian oil were going
to rob Putin of all the funds he needed
to wage this war
we are enforcing the most significant
package of economic sanctions in history
and it's causing significant damage to
Russia's economy
it has caused Russian economy to fight
frankly crater
of course the opposite is true
foolish energy policies in the west
cause Energy prices to spike spending
more money and sending more money of
course into Putin's coffers
now Russia is getting a big assist at
the same time from president XI and John
Kerry's friends at the CCP
while India is also keeping the Russian
energy markets humming meanwhile Russia
simply turns around and uses its North
stream pipeline as a leverage point
the French uh suggesting that there
should be a turn down in heating so that
they're capping the amount of heating
that the energy is being used over the
next few weeks other plans in France
include delaying heat for public
buildings this winter
and now Europe is facing its own
recession and that's going to drag down
the global economy into a very cold
winter
and as for the actual progress of the
war itself the entire thing kind of is
starting to remind me of Iraq lots of
Happy Talk No reality checks Ukraine is
taking back territory from Russia is
this a sign that the war is Shifting do
you think this is indeed a turning point
in the war for Ukraine I mean if this
isn't what would be
we'll say it's uh it's a very good sign
I'm normally fairly guarded and cautious
about this but the tide clearly has
turned
over and over we're told the same
message that we heard about Afghanistan
with just a little bit more money from
the United States in this case Vladimir
Putin will crack
we're going to stay with them as long as
they need our help you're already north
of 15 billion dollars in terms of those
commitments how far do you go as long as
it takes
Ironclad commitment yes
as long as it takes
that could be many years because Putin
just announced he's calling up 300 000
reservists to send to Ukraine 300 000.
did our crack military leadership of
Austin and Millie anticipate any of this
even Tom Friedman the Elite's favorite
Global thinker he's sounding the alarm
saying how does this war end with a
stable result we still don't know the EU
is divided on how to deal with the war
especially where the populist backlashes
emerge when people get totally stressed
this winter some European leaders will
begin to ask is there a way out through
negotiations
well it's a little bit late don't you
think for the establishment to now tell
us that the whole Ukraine Saga may not
have a happy ending
remember the angle was warning you in
March about the risks of a Biden proxy
war
because history shows that the longer a
war lasts the more costly it is the U.S
policy makers have to be very careful to
make sure we do not end up in a worse
position when this is all over but the
American people must be told that the
risks of escalating things with Russia
are not negligible
it may in fact draw us even closer to a
direct confrontation with Russia which
as we all know is a nuclear power
and today we inch closer to the nuclear
cliff
and those who try to Blackmail us with
nuclear weapons should know that the
prevailing winds can also blow in their
direction
if the territorial Integrity of our
country is threatened we will without
doubt use all available means to protect
Russia and our people this is not a
bluff
now amazingly secretary Austin and
general Mark milley the same two who
oversaw the debacle of our withdrawal
from Afghanistan
are still in Biden's cabinet
but incompetence gets people killed here
and the Pentagon is still putting
American lives at risk this time not
just dozens outside of an airport
but perhaps Millions here at home
now we all want the best for the
Ukrainian people they've suffered
greatly it's a terrible tragedy
but you can't run U.S foreign policy on
emotion alone
and by the way one poll more than any
other looking toward the midterms may be
the Bellwether for the prospects the
Democrats
64 percent of the country now say that
we're headed in the wrong direction
and this is a good time to remember what
Biden promised on the campaign Trail
I said I'm running for three reasons one
to restore the soul of America the
decency and honor of this country two to
rebuild the backbone of the country the
backbone of the country or the working
women and men the middle class third
reason Iran was to unify the country to
unify it
well the country's getting unified all
right really United we're getting United
behind the idea that Biden and the
Democrats are dragging us down a rat
hole
no amount of Happy Talk by them by their
press pals are going to change those
facts
now the voters may not agree with
Republicans on everything we know that
but they hate what the Democrats are
doing to America
and that's the angle hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else